I know right?
Whose balls did I have to fondle to get my
very own movie
Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie Marvel just revealed the working title
for Deadpool 3 and it's a huge Easter egg for
Loki season 2 as well as Avengers Secret Wars
King Dynasty with the incursions the time Runs
Out storyline that they're adapting for the
comics so if we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're still doing the special
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 and Star Wars giveaway
so I'll name some more winners during this video
too but Deadpool 3 starts filming in a few weeks
the new working title is tidal wave there are a
lot of people that think that this is a reference
to a specific event in the ultimates comics where
Magneto seeks revenge for the death of Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver in the wave of the ultimatum
event and basically winds up being the entire
ultimate's Marvel Universe versus Magneto is part
of all the X-Men cameos that they're gonna feature
during the movie Patrick Stewart revealed a while
ago that he'd be back as a different version of
Professor X along with a version of Ian McKellen's
version of Magneto in one of the early rumors for
the movie I don't know if this is going to wind up
changing or if it'll wind up sticking but the part
of the plot of the movie as part of Deadpool's is
traveling to different universes as part of his
timeline hopping that gets him on the TVA list
which we know he's doing the rumors that part of
that takes him to a universe where Professor X and
the X-Men sided with Magneto in his Brotherhood
of mutants and took over the planet instead of
trying to stop him like in those original X-Men
movies and it's in that universe that Deadpool
winds up working with a version of Wolverine
played by Hugh Jackman and it's their way of
doing a more comic book accurate looking Wolverine
without trampling or retconning the plot of the
Logan movie or Hugh Jackman's previous X-Men
and Wolverine movies because he'd be a totally
different version from a different universe like
for example how is Wolverine alive yeah after
Logan Logan takes place in 2029 totally separate
thing Logan died in Logan not touching that
whether or not that winds up being the case I also
think the tidal wave working title is meant to be
a general reference to the overall theme of the
plot because Kevin feige revealed that Deadpool
3 would be this cataclysmic Tipping Point in
the Marvel Cinematic Multiverse in their lead
up to Avengers Secret Wars the whole idea is that
they're building towards Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
in Avengers 6 Secret Wars even though there are
a lot of changes from the comics Secret Wars is
meant to be the culmination of all the incursions
mentioned during Doctor Strange Multiverse of
Madness with the universes colliding with one
another winking out of existence like destroying
each other that was what Reid Richards of the
Fantastic Four was worried about and at the end of
the movie in the post-credits scene why Cleo was
so upset at him because he caused an incursion in
the dark dimension her home Dimension Stephen your
arrival here confuses and destabilizes reality
the larger the footprint you leave
behind the greater the risk of an
incursion incursion an incursion occurs when
the boundary between two universes erodes
and they collide destroying one or both entirely
you caused an incursion then we're gonna fix it
also side confirming that doctor strange 3 plot
was going to be him at least part of the movie
Saving the dark dimension saving dormammu's
Dimension because he also controls it but at
the end of the time Runs Out storyline in the
movie version like the MCU version it'll either
be a variant of Kang or a beyonder or whichever
character they wind up going with that combines
the remnants of what's left of reality into a
single world so it's one world for the entire
Multiverse called battle world with a bunch of
the Multiverse characters that are left over
that survived all fighting for Supremacy in the
movie version of things it'll be them trying to
stop whoever winds up creating battle world and
trying to bring back the Multiverse though and it
sounds like part of Marvel's plan with Deadpool 3
is to have Deadpool just muck up his time travel
device so much caused so many Nexus events that
they Loosely adapt a version of Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe where he kind of causes a
bunch of different incursions to domino effect
destroy reality much much faster it be very in the
tone of Deadpool to accidentally wind up almost
is destroying all of reality like he ends the
movie escaping the TVA like he's successful in
running from Mobius Miss minutes the other
TVA characters but because the movie is a
loose adaptation of Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe he almost winds up killing the entire
Marvel Multiverse the final title of the movie
will be something different that they use in all
the marketing put on all the posters and it'll
have Wolverine in it just because Hugh Jackman
Wolverine is such a big character in the movie
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman were joking about
what that would be recently which at the time when
you Jackman posted his video clowning on him he
referred to the movie as Wolverine and Deadpool
so a lot of people thought that that might be the
title of the film I mean I have to spend a year
with him shooting Wolverine and Deadpool Wolverine
Deadpool because he kitten not in your life chappy
in the sly teaser at the end of Ryan Reynolds
video here where he pretends like he accidentally
left the camera on and revealed how pissed off he
was throwing shade of the title not on your life
chappie also calling it Wolverine and Deadpool
the reason why he calls Hugh Jackman chappie if
you forgot Hugh Jackman was in the chappie movie
with Sigourney Weaver it was something else he
had quite the haircut in that he was also using
his real Australian accent let's just say the
chappie movie did not perform as good as some of
his other films so Ryan Reynolds was just making
fun of him under his breath a little calling out
one of his worst movies Wolverine and Deadpool are
you kidding not in your life chappy they do that
to each other all the time like they make fun of
each other's other movies non-marvel movies all
the time but because both of them referred to the
movie as Wolverine and Deadpool that does make you
wonder if that is the official title of Deadpool
3 or if Ryan Reynolds reaction post means that
they're actually going to call it Deadpool and
Wolverine like there's no way he's going to let
them call it Wolverine and Deadpool like no way
Wolverine gets to put his name first in the title
the movie is meant to be a direct continuation of
the events of Deadpool 2 where Deadpool ended the
movie taking Cable's time travel device visiting
several points in his timeline as well as other
timelines changing the past like killing a
variant from his own timeline the original
weird looking version of Deadpool and Wolverine
Origins he killed a version of himself in another
timeline before he made the Green Lantern movie
he messed with Baby Hitler and they're just gonna
say that he continued messing with timelines
in the fox Marvel Universe until eventually
he tries to save a younger Wolverine from dying
earlier in his timeline like before the events of
the Logan movie but one day your old pal Wade is
going to ask you to get back in the saddle again
and when he does say yes and that's how Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine becomes part of the plot
when they first meet they fight like Deadpool
versus Wolverine or Wolverine versus Deadpool
however you think about it Hugh Jackman's been
revealing the plot just joking about how his
Wolverine can't stand Deadpool as you would expect
they talked about this in their big teaser video
last year but part of the joke of the characters
like The Comedy of a Deadpool movie with Wolverine
is that both of them have crazy healing factors
so they would just be able to lay into each
other chopping every bit of their bodies off and
healing it almost instantly so the fight would
just go on forever eventually the TVA detects
all the changes the Deadpool is making to the
timelines he's causing so much Havoc destroying
the timelines the TVA Mobius Miss minutes come
after him and that's how they get involved in
the plot that's how they explain this is a Marvel
movie because those are core Marvel characters
now in the MCU I don't know if Tom hiddleston's
Loki will also have a cameo in the movie because
they're supposed to have so many different cameos
in the movie let me know in the comments what do
you want the actual title of Deadpool 3 to be if
Wolverine were not in the movie I would have said
they should just call it Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe because it's already a perfect title but
since Wolverine is such a big part of it I'm fine
with him calling it Deadpool and Wolverine like
if they have to have Wolverine in the title that'd
probably be what they would call it just expect
Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds to continue joking
about what the actual title will be like who gets
top billing will be called Wolverine and Deadpool
or Deadpool and Wolverine until they finally make
the announcement reportedly we'll be getting Loki
season 2 later this year and we won't have to
wait till next year I'm working on a brand new
Loki season 2 trailer video that should post
pretty soon and speaking of the Marvel Universe
because Guardians of the Galaxy 3 just came out
James Gunn also just said that the Deadpool movies
are some of his favorite comic book movies of
all time I think coming in at number five I'm
gonna go with Deadpool the first Deadpool and the
second Deadpool actually are two of my favorite
comic book movies they came on the heels of
the Guardians film they were even more of you
know comedies in the Guardians films are and they
were so well made so heartfelt and fun and Ryan
Reynolds just kills it I think Deadpool is the
perfect adaptation of a comic book because the
comic book is very much tongue-in-cheek very much
breaking the fourth wall all the time talking to
the audience and I think the movie does that
really well but somehow also keeps it more
grounded and gives it a little bit more heart than
the comics have you could see me you'd understand
looks on everything looks are everything ever
heard David Beckham speak it's like a mouth sex
to can a helium I think Ryan Reynolds got this far
on a superior acting method Love is Blind Wade no
you're blind Brian's such a funny guy I think it
along with like Robert Downey Jr is Iron Man or
Christopher Reeve is Superman he's one of the
all-time great comic book you know icons it's
really cool to hear him gush about the Deadpool
movies makes me really excited for Deadpool 3.
congratulations to the giveaway winners from my
last couple of Marvel and Star Wars videos Xavier
Ramirez 2397 and Brad 4231 please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get your contact
details everyone click here for all my Deadpool 3
videos and click here for my Loki season 2 trailer
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one